does anyone else remember when M night
Shyamalan was supposed to direct this
movie I was following it like I was
legitimately interested in this movie
then when he stopped was like who cares
and then when Angley picked it up I was
like huh Life of Pi is an adaptation of
a book that's very famous a lot of
people didn't think that a book like
this could be adapted it's basically the
story about a kid who grows up in India
that eventually gets shipwrecked with
just himself and a tiger on a boat and
it's basically his adventure of how he
tries to survive without getting eaten
by sharks about dying of starvation and
without getting eaten by the tiger and
also forming a bond with the animal as
well and it's kind of like castaway
without the island and although there is
a sense of realism to what takes place
in the film like the actual events it
feels kind of like a fantasy as well
this movie is directed by Angley and
it's a visual masterpiece I can tell you
that right off the bat it's a completely
seamless blend of CGI and in-camera
stunt work it's really astounding this
movie has some incredible visuals and
there were many times in this movie
where I actually got goose bumps like
shiver inducing visuals really stunning
stuff the 3d is eye popping like there
is a legitimate use of 3d in this movie
like there's even a scene that was
released unfortunately beforehand was
one of the best scenes in the movie and
I wish I hadn't have seen it where these
fish that are like flying or jumping
around and they added black bars to the
top in the bottom of the screen all of a
sudden and they had like the fish jump
out around the bars and everything and
it made it look like they were really
jumping out of the frame it was really
interesting there was really good use of
3d in this movie and before I get into
anything else I should just say if
you're actually going to see this movie
I would suggest this is weird for me to
say to actually see it in 3d I usually
don't make that kind of suggestion I
usually say whatever it's 2d you cares
this movie is a 3d experience for sure
let's get a little bit more in depth
about this movie see the first half-hour
so this movie is a lot of character
development you don't really get to the
meat of the film until 32 maybe even 40
minutes into the movie is when you
really starts to pick up and at first I
was like I really hope this goes a
little faster because there's a lot of
development with him as a kid you know
and you meet girls that he likes me and
learn about his family and everything
and it wasn't until the shipwreck
actually happens that I realized the
true significance of that opening
because although it did drag a little
bit and I must admit that it had much
more of an impact when he is actually
marooned
ship because I was like wow yes I
actually understood him more as a
character the character development
helped I think maybe they could have
brought back a little less and not had
that opening be so long and gotten to
the meat a little bit faster but it
definitely added more to his character
the shipwreck sequence with breathtaking
and see the ocean kind of creeps me out
like I've always had a fear of it you
know all the creatures in it and getting
stranded in the ocean it's always been a
fear of mine so there were a lot of
times this movie ride just like I'd like
the hood like the hair stood up on the
back of my neck the main actor of this
film I cannot pronounce his name he did
an excellent job in this movie he worked
so well with a CGI tiger which was also
mind-blowing me well animated like it
was just that is a thing that's a
creature right there and it's real yes I
mean this part of you that knows it's
CGI it looks so fantastic and I can't
give enough props to the people who did
the special effects for this movie
they're beautiful I do have a few issues
with the Fellman largely their script
based it seemed like the first half hour
40 minutes did drag a little bit even
though was building up his character it
does the thing where like you hear from
him as an adult and he's telling
somebody a story and then you see the
story I just I've seen that so many
times in movies and I was like could you
maybe I don't know I just seemed like it
could have been done a different way
something about those scenes where he
was talking to the writer who's thinking
about writing about this story and
telling him his life story and
everything something about it just
seemed a little fake but overall Life of
Pi is a really striking visual film and
that's really what this movie is it's a
visual experience on that level it
succeeds a lot like it's just like wow
like there are shots in this movie where
I was just sitting there like it that's
that's astounding like just truly
beautiful imagery a good performance
amazing CGI really actually a very
original movie I mean you keep there
really is no other movie where a kid
stranded on a boat with a tiger and
tries to tame it I mean it just you know
you don't see that if you're a fan of
the book I think you'll appreciate this
movie I did have a few issues with a
script and so I'm going to give the film
a B+ however I think you should
definitely check it out at some point
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this and you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes